[Music]
this video is in partnership with Best
Buy all right what's up I'm Kim BHD here
and we're in that wrapping up 2021 phase
as you already know did that first
rewind video which was all about the
biggest most influential Tech of all of
2021 and videos like that are way more
varied and off the wall just because
there's a lot of different Tech that has
an impact on the year but not all that
stuff's relatable or stuff that you can
get your hands on right now so this
video this video is specifically for
stuff that you can get right now this is
for this is the top 10 gadgets that you
can actually get your hands on that came
out in the last 365 days and with
partnering with Best Buy on this video
you already guessed it every single one
of the items on this list you can go to
a store right now or go to bestbuy.com
and pick up for yourself but also the
benefit of Best Buy having physical
stores is you can actually go to a store
and see some of these things in person
for yourself which a little underrated
so I've had the opportunity to stay
ahead of the curve with a lot of this
Tech this year from from Best Buy and
yeah getting to see some of it in person
before you buy it makes a big difference
you'll see what I mean in a second so
sit back relax maybe open another tab
because all this stuff is linked down
below if you want to check it out right
away and let's get into it so number 10.
number 10 is the Beats fit Pro okay so
these came out during the second half of
the Year pretty late and I didn't even
get to review them but they are my
favorite Beats headphones ever for a
couple of reasons one they're the best
sounding beats ever by a lot but two
it's the design that actually stays
locked in your ear so wing tips major
key and so because of the Great Sound
and great fit these pretty much
instantly became my favorite workout
headphones so if you're in need of a
pair like that I'd say look no further
they also have a decently small case and
a solid battery life and of course
they're sweat resistant for that workout
stuff and if you can you can go to a
Best Buy and see the different colors in
person plus you can check out pretty
much any other headphones they have at
all so that can help you pick your
favorite so number nine is the Samsung
Galaxy Z fold three
so I was kind of torn between putting
this or the flip 3 on this list but the
point is there are some of the most
interesting phones that came out this
year yes of course we got the candy bar
phones getting better and having bigger
batteries and better cameras and all
that's great but these phones do a lot
different obviously the hidden selfie
camera behind the display folding in
half and they're just more complete and
capable than ever so the flip 3 just
made the whole folding phone as a daily
driver thing way more attainable for
many people with the price tag right in
line with other phones people buy all
the time it's worth checking out in
person in a store if you can just to see
how much that crease may or may not
bother you or whether or not you even
notice it or care about it but Pro tip
when you're actually using these phones
both the crease and the hidden selfie
camera I noticed really kind of
disappear to the eye as you focus on the
actual content on the phone so you get a
much bigger screen as a result either
way really looking forward to these
continuing to get better alright so
number eight and I could have gone kind
of anywhere with this because this was a
really good year for cameras but I'm
gonna go with the Sony Alpha One one of
their flagships this is an expensive one
but it did a lot of things right and I
really like this camera so this is the
full frame mirrorless camera it's
stuffed to the gills with features high
resolution High frame rate high shutter
speed lots of auto focus points great
color science and that's just for photos
Sony's also been crushing the mirrorless
video game for the past few years at a
bunch of different price brackets and
this one slots in basically right at the
top of their lineup it's so good I
honestly look forward to shooting videos
with it we've shot videos including the
setup Tour on the studio Channel with it
and also the Tesla Model Y review on the
main Channel which was shot entirely on
the A1 with that full frame sensor we've
got plenty of glass for it the autofocus
was great it was just a great year for
cameras so it's hard to pick just one
but the A1 was a beast alright so number
seven
the Galaxy S21 Ultra from Samsung again
so this may seem like okay now this is a
little bit more of a boring option
compared to the fold and the flip that
were here before but the fold in the
flip made this list for me because
they're influential and really
interesting phones this makes a list
just because it's their best phone and
honestly I think it's one of the best
phones Samsung has made in a long time
miles better than the s20 ultra of
course huge Improvement great battery
world-class display great performance
and really great cameras and honestly I
really like this design not just because
it's matte black of course but the whole
thing the intentional leaning into the
camera bump the weight the materials
everything about this build I really
like now it's also a huge phone so if
you're trying to actually get one I'd
say check it out in person just to make
sure it's not dramatically different
from what you're expecting but yeah huge
thumbs up for me on what often doesn't
get talked about enough this early in
the year Flagship so number six I am
giving to the Nintendo switch OLED the
new one
they kind of nailed it so obviously the
original switch was very popular just as
a portable handheld gaming console and
we've seen some others now jump into
this same form factor the same space but
the switch OLED is just an all-around
better version of the switch we already
knew and loved much smaller bezels
better display of course it's in the
name deeper blacks and a much brighter
punchier look to it and it's much better
with that full width kickstand so it's
kind of the ideal refresh and I've had
plenty of fun flights with the original
switch so can't really go wrong with the
new Switch here switch OLED is great all
right number five this one might be kind
of out of left field but I believe in it
a lot apples air tags so this is one of
the most influential products of the
entire year mainly because it shined a
huge Spotlight on this industry and we
got to see how all of the competitors
already in it would react mainly tile we
got to see how tile would react I am
somehow always surprised by how many
people suddenly have intense and deep
thoughts and care a lot about a product
category as soon as Apple enters it even
if it was pretty chill before but the
Apple effect is real and they have
pulled a lot of other companies into
their orbit too so not only can you find
your keys anytime you lose them with a
keychain for air tags but now other
companies are making air tags compatible
wallets and air tags backpack sleeves
and air tags clamps for anything and
everything you might lose of any size to
find with Apple's fine my network it's
great it's very handy and it was a
pretty important product of the year and
while we're at it number four the iPhone
13 series but if I can be more specific
I want to shine a spotlight on the
iPhone 13 mini for a second so tiny
flagships are a Dying Breed they have
been for a while we've known this
already and so Apple comes out with
their entire iPhone 13 lineup again this
year they've got an iPhone 13 an iPhone
13 Pro a pro Max and a mini and they did
the mini phone right they did it the
correct way which is that all of the
phones and the whole lineup more or less
have the same specs so the only
difference between them is screen size
and battery size so the iPhone 13 mini
has the exact same super powerful chip
as all the bigger phones it has the same
massive new primary camera sensor as all
the bigger phones with improved
stabilization and it actually has a
physically larger battery than the 12
mini which struggled a bit with that
last year so if there were ever a good
time to get a mini phone I think it's
now considering all the rumors that
there might not be another one next year
and of course you can head into Best Buy
and check out the Mini's size for
yourself you can literally hold it up
next to your current phone for
comparison to see how compact it really
is but shout out to the mini Flagship
smartphone alright so number three
this is a really fun one this is the DJI
fpv drone this thing is incredible so as
I broke down in my review video this
thing is basically combining all the
best of two very different drone worlds
which is the cinematography tools and
recreational drones that DJI already
kind of dominates and the DIY first
person view racing drones that you might
catch on TV or on a local park sometimes
and the result combining them is this
incredibly fun high performance droning
experience with a decently high quality
camera and a pair of goggles wirelessly
connected I've literally never had more
fun with a drone than with this one it
can go 90 plus miles an hour in sport
mode but you sort of slowly work your
way up to that and you can unlock more
and more levels of manual control to get
there and don't worry it comes with a
bunch of extra propellers too in case
you get too close to some trees or Take
a Tumble or two I've done that too we've
all done it but I love this drone
alright so number two is Google's pixel
6 series and mainly the smaller less
expensive pixel 6 which I think is a
great phone and a great deal so this was
Google's first time designing the chip
inside so there's a tensor chip powering
this phone they're clearly focused a lot
still on the cameras which are quite
good too especially on a phone of this
price and I think it has some room for a
little higher ceiling with some software
updates but really this phone is all
about having the most convenient Google
features Google Assistant answering
phone calls and waiting on hold for you
and working on the background it's great
it's one of the reasons I choose to use
a pixel so often as my main phone all
that phone for 5.99 in the pixel 6. now
I do personally daily the more expensive
6 Pro not a whole ton of difference
really between them but if you want to
test your eye to see if you noticed a
slightly higher refresh rate or the
slightly higher resolution display
that's worth a shot so then last but not
least number one is the new Macbook Pros
the new M1 Pro and M1 1 Pro Max 14 inch
and 16 inch MacBook Pros these things
have been incredible now same deal there
have been a lot of really good laptops
all over the map this year but these
made the biggest splash of course
because of the incredible performance
and efficiency all that comes with the
new Apple silicon that went into these
machines and the way it applied
specifically to my own workflow I loved
it these have been great so you can
check out my entire review video if you
want all the benchmarks and details of
my real world experiences with these
laptops but bottom line it makes a
fantastic only computer for a lot of
different creatives professionals Etc
I've edited videos on the 16-inch M1 Max
a lot of my colleagues and friends are
loving the 14 inch M1 Pro just as much
the notch is kind of like a kind of like
the crease in the Samsung folding phones
like when you're actually using the
device it fades away to the eye and
becomes a non-factor even if it is a
head scratcher why it's there in the
first place but the displays themselves
are world class with high dynamic range
High brightness High refresh rate and
high resolution the speakers are Best in
Class the battery life is top of the
class and it has all the ports I mean
what more could you really ask for so
there you have it 10 gadgets that came
out during the last 365 days that are
really influential or really good
turns out it was a pretty good year
after all also I want to toss in because
I was doing my research for this video
and I realized it didn't come out this
year but the Quest 2 the VR headset if
you're in the market for one it's still
honestly still the best like portable VR
experience Standalone that you can get
right now so I'm going to just toss that
in there also didn't come out this year
but Sony's
wh-1000xm4 noise canceling headphones if
you don't have or haven't tried one of
the over ear pairs from Sony yet
really good so I'm just gonna include
those at the end but that's a little
extra and thanks again to Best Buy for
partnering on this video you already
know they have all the best tech
available all year round so whether it's
actually going into a Best Buy store to
check out something physically in person
for yourself or just going to buy what
you already know you want from
bestbuy.com they've got it all all year
round and they've been awesome for all
things Tech so that's been it thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace